1989 lui s orléans créé l'exploit face
au psg
robbie langueur et ce magnifique but
à cette époque les orléanais s'impose et
la ville s'enflamme va neuf ans plus
tard nous avons rencontré les anciens
joueurs
aujourd'hui ils vivent aux quatre coins
de la france mais exceptionnellement
match oblige ils se sont dit oui pour
des retrouvailles et cette fois ci sans
crampons on a tous les mêmes souvenirs
l'arrivée au parc où il a découvert du
parc le match retour à la source
le public était dans la tribune un stade
plein comme un oeuf et une ambiance un
peu particulière dans la fin des mages
on pense il avait dit le résultat paris
saint-germain orléans 4 et les
commentateurs vietnam et vous trompez
c'est 4 à 0 et menace est bien géré au
carton plein donc ça ça me met tout dire
mais c'est vrai qu'on aurait fait un
match superbe et l'équipe actuelle de
l'ue sos perd à son tour pourquoi pas
résisté au psg
un psg beaucoup plus grand et combatif
aujourd'hui rien d'effrayant pour
certains tops aux pronostics le match ce
sera ce soir même s'il ya un pour cent
de chances de se qualifier match reste
un match et je leur souhaite de faire un
bon match et pourquoi pas laisse moi et
pour les réunir il a fallu beaucoup de
patience et de la logistique mais au
final quel bonheur de se retrouver
beaucoup de temps ça m'a pris beaucoup
d'énergie beaucoup de petits soucis et
effectivement je suis un peu ému parce
que pourquoi la fête c'est ce soir et
puis effectivement tout a une fin
on va se quitter ce soir au bout de 30
ans on verra peut-être pas vannes neuf
ans plus tard ses anciens joueurs
n'auraient manqué pour rien au monde
cette ambiance délirante d'avant match
[Musique]